they've rebuilt the bridge now the
motorway traffic to the west of kiev
looks normal
but when the history of this war is
written a chapter will be saved for the
m06 and the e40 highway
killing ground for russian soldiers that
ukraine will never forget
the police say the attacks on civilians
along this road lasted from february
28th to about the end of the first week
of march
they're still investigating the killings
of dozens and dozens of people in cold
blood
the collective shock hasn't gone
they've saved the cars that were shot up
by the russians in a series of breakers
yards
most are burnt out but many are as they
were
the possessions of the families still
inside
the blood on the seats is dry now
the bullet holes are cold
well this um
this these cars are all part of a
investigation into what happened on
the main
road that takes you into the west
of kiev that's the m06
and the e40
these are mainly almost exclusively
being driven by uh civilians
um
many of them were hit by
tank rounds set on fire
or just
shot up
you can see a lot of i mean people
many many people died
on this road
in what we now pretty much know and
talking to police investigators saying
it was at this quite at the beginning of
the war
and uh it was the russians attempting uh
to move into the capital and they wanted
this road to get uh through it the
bridge had actually been blown so it
probably meant that their movement came
to an end we know that a man
we're not certain which car but one of
these a man um was uh killed and uh this
video showing him uh dead on the side of
the road this is a family vehicle
you can see inside we know that large
numbers of families were
shot and and many of them killed as they
tried to escape
as the war uh got nearer and this is the
car i was driving in as well um
we
five of us got out of this i i submit
it's
quite amazing uh really i got out this
side but everywhere we had been
um
uh there's bullet uh holes in in in the
seats etc
uh also up in the in the roof it was a
professional hit the the police
certainly no doubt about that what's
interesting is
what the soldiers will tell you is the
grouping of the bullets so the first
sets
of bullets were to try to kill the
driver which would be these ones uh to
the right
and then uh left to the passenger seat
and then slightly across and you can see
we would probably certainly richie
mukler our cameraman who was in the
front was pretty much saved by the
engine block which took uh quite a lot
of the
rounds in the days that followed the
attack on us police say 20 people were
killed on the same short stretch of road
the burnt out hulks of vehicles stayed
untouched for weeks
it's believed russians burnt the cars
with bodies of the dead inside to cover
up their crimes
locals filmed this vehicle as it was set
on fire
it belonged to a family they knew had
been trying to get away they were shot
at by russian soldiers
so hey stotzky and his baby daughter
anna were injured but survived and were
allowed to leave by the russians after
pleading with them
was killed immediately and witnesses say
her body burnt in the car
she was just 28 years old
i have a reason to live and i try to
recover as fast as possible just because
i have a small child and they need to
perfect her
because i couldn't protect my wife
and you know i feel guilty about this
the war is far from over of course for
now it's moved to the east but it could
easily return
the locations and the memorials aren't
part of history yet
we're still on the first draft
still ramsey sky news keefe